Il primo di tre incontri
Il festival di quest'anno è dedicato alla creatività. Accostare la creatività con la guerra da un lato può sembrare un paradosso e il titolo stesso di creatività distruttrice può in qualche modo sembrare uno simolo, un accostamento di due cose opposte.
D'altra parte è inevitabile ammettere che l'uomo nel fare la guerra ha sempre investito enormi risorse e non soltanto risorse economiche, materiali ma anche risorse di inventiva e sì di creatività.
Potrebbe anche sembrare una cosa ovvia in realtà perché tutto sommato si è sempre parlato di arte della guerra e i grandi generali sono sempre stati celebrati, magari senza troppo chiedersi se era giusto o no, come se fossero dei grandi uomini in assoluto.
Alla pari dei grandi artisti, Napoleone e Leonardo, due grandi uomini.
Però qui quello che io vorrei cercare di fare con voi non sarà semplicemente raccontare come in una battaglia i comandanti danno prova di creatività o esercitano la loro intelligenza.
Questo in fondo viene sempre fatto nella storia militare.
Quello che io vorrei fare con voi è qualcosa di un po' diverso e cioè da un lato naturalmente raccontare queste battaglie perché se si promette di parlare di Lepanto credo che non potrei cavarmela facilmente se non vi raccontassi anche la battaglia di Lepanto.
Però io vorrei qui fare anche un'altra cosa e cioè di ognuna di queste battaglie che è uno scontro fra due eserciti o fra due flotte come a Lepanto, io vorrei fermarmi con voi e riflettere un momento su come sono stati messi in piedi questi eserciti e queste flotte.
Cosa voleva dire? Che a un certo punto poche migliaia di uomini come a Campaldino o 150.000 come a Lepanto e a Waterloo si trovavano ad affrontarsi organizzati, armati in un certo modo.
Com'è che quelle società avevano potuto mettere in campo delle forze del genere? Qual era tutto il tesoro di esperienza e di inventiva e di creatività che c'era alle spalle?
Può darsi che ora io sia stato un po' vago nel dichiarare lo scopo ma mi importava che fosse chiaro che uno scopo c'è al di là del puro e semplice racconto degli avvenimenti, delle battaglie e poi forse nel concreto esemplificando si capirà meglio quello che più o meno ho cercato di dirvi.
Cominciamo dunque da Campaldino, 1289.
Campaldino è forse la meno nota fra queste tre battaglie di cui parleremo, però penso che in molti evochi comunque ricordi scolastici, forse non tanto per la sua importanza storica quanto per il fatto che ci ha combattuto Dante.
Dante aveva una ventina d'anni al tempo di Campaldino ed era uno dei cavalieri dell'esercito fiorentino che si sono affrontati in quel giorno con l'esercito di Arezzo e dei ghibellini toscani e che hanno vinto quella battaglia.
E quindi è forse più per questo che non per il significato storico dell'evento che molti di noi possono avere in mente questa battaglia che Dante del resto, e lo vedremo, cita nella Divina Commedia più di una volta.
Campaldino è un momento storicamente importante perché segna una tappa in un'evoluzione i cui risultati sentiamo ancora oggi.
Il fatto cioè che in Toscana la città dominante è Firenze e non per esempio Siena o Pisa, come avrebbe potuto succedere.
Campaldino è una tappa dell'affermazione dell'egemonia di Firenze che si afferma come la più potente di tutte le altre città toscane e soffoca le altre città toscane,
ed è una tappa dello scontro fra Guelfi e Ghibellini che in Toscana si conclude sostanzialmente con il trionfo della parte Guelfa su quella ghibellina.
Quando si combatte a Campaldino nel 1289 che le cose stavano andando così si era già capito in realtà.
Tra i Guelfi e i Ghibellini era già abbastanza evidente che in Italia centrale stavano triunfando i Guelfi.
Qui mi fermo un attimo perché mi rendo conto che da specialista di Medioevo magari do troppe cose per scontate.
Cosa vuol dire Guelfi e Ghibellini?
Diciamolo in due parole.
Diciamo che nell'Italia dei Comuni, in cui ogni città si era presa il potere, tutto, e si comportava come uno Stato, faceva leggi, giudicava dei processi,
batteva spesso anche moneta e così via, nell'Italia dei Comuni e dove quindi le città si combattevano fra loro e si distruggevano a vicenda,
a un certo punto qualcuno aveva cominciato a pensare che forse questa meravigliosa libertà che permetteva a ogni città di comportarsi come uno Stato indipendente non era proprio in assoluto l'ideale.
Qualcuno aveva cominciato a pensare che forse in Italia sarebbe stato meglio se fosse successo quel che succedeva in Francia, in Inghilterra,
dove una monarchia imponeva un minimo di ordine, facendo pagare in cambio moltissime tasse, ben inteso.
In Italia c'era un re, era l'imperatore, l'imperatore tedesco che giuridicamente era anche re d'Italia, e questo sulla carta non lo negava nessuno,
il problema è che ci si era abituati a che questo imperatore in Italia non ci venisse e quando veniva ci restasse pochissimo tempo
e permettesse agli italiani di fare lo stesso tutto quello che volevano.
A un certo momento nasce un partito che invece chiede all'imperatore, stiamo parlando di un secolo e mezzo prima di Campaldino,
questa è una storia lunga, stiamo parlando dell'epoca di Federico Barbarossa,
nasce un partito che pensa che forse l'imperatore dovrebbe invece venirci in Italia
e dovrebbe, quando va via, lasciare dei suoi funzionari,
collocare in ogni città un uomo di fiducia che possa assicurare un minimo di uniformità al governo del paese
e impedire alle città di farsi la guerra fra loro.
Quelli che sono d'accordo con questa idea, che dopo tutto l'imperatore dovrebbe regnare,
a un certo punto prenderanno il nome di Ghibellini.
Ci sono molti altri che non sono affatto d'accordo.
Ci sono molte città, specialmente le più grosse,
quelle che stanno mangiando i vicini e che si stanno imponendo come dominanti nelle loro regioni,
Milano, Firenze, che trovano che c'è tutto da guadagnare in questa libertà di espandersi come si vuole
e c'è tutto da perdere se l'imperatore ricomincia a governare.
Di conseguenza queste città si oppongono fieramente al progetto di ricostituire un regno funzionante in Italia
e trovano un appoggio.
Trovano l'appoggio dell'altro grande potere universale
che con l'imperatore non va tanto d'accordo, da un pezzo, il papato,
il papato del tutto naturalmente si propone come il protettore e il finanziatore di quelle città
che non vogliono che l'imperatore torni a governare.
E quindi si crea di fronte alla parte dell'impero una parte della chiesa,
che più tardi prenderà il nome di parte Guelfa.
Quindi lo scontro fra Guelfi e Ghibellini, di cui Campaldino è una tappa,
è uno scontro fra due federazioni di città, di grandi famiglie nobili,
alcune delle quali individuano nell'imperatore il loro riferimento internazionale,
altre invece lo individuano nel papato,
e anche nella monarchia francese che col papato è strettamente alleata.
Ora nel 1289 vi dicevo,
spero che basti come riassunto delle lezioni di scuola
per capire cosa intendiamo quando parliamo di Guelfi e Ghibellini.
Nel 1289, come vi dicevo,
in Toscana, almeno in Toscana, a Milano no,
ma in Toscana si capisce che i Guelfi stanno vincendo, nettamente.
Qualche altro ricordo scolastico.
Nel 1266 è venuto in Italia Carlo d'Angio,
quindi un principe francese,
alleato con i Guelfi e con il Papa.
Ha sconfitto Manfredi alla battaglia di Benevento,
si è impadronito del Regno di Napoli.
A partire da quel momento è chiaro che in tutta l'Italia centro-meridionale
i Guelfi, la parte del Papa e la parte di Firenze,
stanno prevalendo.
Due anni dopo è venuto Corradino di Svevia
a tentare di risollevare la causa dei Ghibellini e dell'Impero.
È stato sconfitto da Carlo d'Angio,
decapitato, sconfitto alla battaglia di Tagliacozzo.
1268.
Nel 69 un'altra coalizione di Ghibellini toscani
è stata sconfitta dai Guelfi toscani
e la battaglia di Colle Valdelsa.
Sembrerebbe che non ci sia più storia,
tanto che perfino Siena,
che era stata ostinatamente Ghibellina fino a quel momento,
a un certo momento passa alla parte Guelfa.
Rimangono Ghibelline, Pisa, Arezzo,
qualche nobile della montagna
che non ha ancora capito come dire il vento,
come i conti guidi.
Bene, nel 1289 c'è di nuovo un'occasione di scontro
fra questi avanzi del partito Ghibellino
e i Guelfi,
cappeggiati da Firenze.
In Arezzo c'è una minoranza Guelfa
che vorrebbe buttare fuori i Ghibellini,
prendere il potere e portare anche Arezzo
nell'alleanza Guelfa.
Invece i Ghibellini sono abbastanza forti in città
e sono loro che buttano fuori i Guelfi.
Questo si faceva normalmente nelle guerre interne dei comuni.
La parte che perdeva le elezioni, diciamo così,
di solito poteva aspettarsi di essere espulsa dalla città,
di vedere i suoi palazzi rasi al suolo,
i suoi beni confiscati.
Per fortuna c'erano le città amiche,
le città governate dai compagni di partito,
per cui i Guelfi,
espulsi da Arezzo,
vanno a Firenze a chiedere aiuto.
E il governo di Firenze ordina a quello di Arezzo
di riammettere i Ghibellini.
E gli Aretini sono molto perplessi
perché sanno di essere più deboli.
Però anche piegarsi in questo modo
a un'intimazione che arriva da un'altra città
vuol dire proprio avere rinunciato completamente
a essere un comune degno di questo nome.
Esitano.
Ci si mette in mezzo il Vescovo di Arezzo,
che è una potenza per conto suo.
I Vescovi a quest'epoca spesso possiedono
enormi proprietà, fortificate, castelli,
quindi fanno la loro politica,
che non sempre è la politica del comune.
Il Vescovo di una città può anche litigare
con il suo comune.
È una potenza autonoma.
Quello di Arezzo però è un Ghibellino,
un vecchio Ghibellino,
Guglielmino degli Ubertini,
uno di quei Vescovi che nel 200
stavano un po' passando di moda,
ma che era un Vescovo all'antica
di grande famiglia nobile,
abituato a andare a caccia,
andare in guerra quando ce n'era bisogno.
Dice il cronista Dino Compagni
che il Vescovo di Arezzo
sapea meglio gli uffici della guerra
che della Chiesa.
Dicevo che stavano passando di moda
perché nel 200 ormai ci sono
i primi Vescovi francescani,
domenicani,
scelti apposta perché hanno un altro background,
un'altra preparazione anche spirituale,
però ce ne sono ancora
come Guglielmino degli Ubertini.
Guglielmino degli Ubertini esita,
ha una gran paura
che se scoppia la guerra
tra Firenze e Arezzo,
il primo a andarci di mezzo sia lui
che ha dei bei castelli
proprio in mezzo fra le due città,
Bibbiena per esempio.
Esita,
cerca di mettersi d'accordo
di nascosto con i Fiorentini,
i quali sono disposti a pagargli
una grossa somma
se passa dalla loro parte.
Ci sono già dei banchieri
che hanno già stanziato i fondi.
Poi però il Vescovo si rende conto
che appena salterà fuori questa cosa,
ad Arezzo gli faranno la pelle.
Nel Consiglio Comunale di Arezzo
ci sono i suoi parenti
che gli dicono
guarda che c'è all'ordine del giorno
l'idea se si debba ammazzarti
e dicono
noi abbiamo detto
che non eravamo d'accordo
o meglio se l'avessero fatto
senza dircelo
potevamo ancora starci.
Ecco,
a questo punto
notate che non si inventa niente qui,
questo è tutto testuale
nei cronisti dell'epoca.
A questo punto
il Vescovo di Arezzo
ci ripensa e dice
va bene,
allora facciamo questa guerra
contro i Fiorentini
se non c'è nient'altro da fare.
Aiutatemi voi
a difendere i miei castelli
e quindi scoppia la guerra
e i Fiorentini
mettono in campo un esercito
e gli Aretini
e i Fiorentini
che sono i più forti
decidono di invadere
il territorio di Arezzo
si trovano tutti i comandanti
i cavalieri più esperti
anche i capi mercenari
che sono stati assoldati
quelli che vengono
dalle città amiche
che hanno portato
dei contingenti di cavalieri
si trovano tutti
nel Battistero di Firenze
e lì discutono
se sia meglio
fare la strada del Valdarno
o fare la strada
del Casentino
perché all'epoca
non c'è l'idea
che poi si affremerà
in epoca moderna
che un esercito
ha un comandante
e deve essere lui
che decide
all'epoca sono in tanti
quelli che hanno voce
in capitolo
è tutto molto democratico
alla fine si vota
e fra tutti i presenti
in questa assemblea
nel San Giovanni
di Firenze
vince
quella parte
che decide
di che vuole andare
per il Casentino
vanno per il Casentino
appena si viene a sapere
gli aretini
escono con le loro forze militari
e vanno a sbarrargli la strada
si incontrano
nella pianura di Poppi
proprio davanti
a quel castello di Bibbiena
che il vescovo
voleva a tutti i costi difendere
arrivano lì
questi due eserciti
comprendono cavalleria
i fiorentini hanno qualcosa
come 1500 cavalieri
quelli di Arezzo
ne hanno molti meno
8-900
poi c'è della fanteria
conta meno
in combattimento
ma c'è
sono
gli artigiani
delle città
armati
con i loro scudi di legno
con le loro picche
piantano i loro scudi di legno
perché il compito
della cavalleria
è di attaccare
i fanti
basta che stiano fermi
se tengono la posizione
è già più che sufficiente
piantano in terra
i loro scudi di legno
tutti dipinti di nuovo
e
questo schieramento
dei fiorentini
è così imponente
che il vescovo di Arezzo
quando arriva
lo vede in lontananza
e ci dicono i cronisti
che il vescovo di Arezzo
era miope
e quindi
non capisce che cos'è
dice appunto
Dino Compagni
cito a memoria
è il vescovo di Arezzo
il quale aveva corta vista
domandò
quelle che mura sono
gli fu risposto
i pavesi degli nemici
dove i pavesi sono appunto
questi enormi scudi di legno
bene
ma che cosa vuol dire
che i fiorentini
avevano 1500 cavalieri
e li avevano portati lì
e cosa vuol dire
che avevano
della fanteria
la quale però contava
molto meno
dei cavalieri
e quindi stava ferma
dietro i suoi scudi
e chi erano
quei cavalieri
e come erano armati
e come era stato deciso
chi ci doveva andare
perché erano organizzati
così questi eserciti
io mi rendo conto
che porsi queste domande
è forse un po' meno divertente
che continuare a raccontare
la battaglia
botte da orbi
e così via
faremo anche quello
però noi qui
almeno
voi ci siete cascati
io
mi sono proposto
di fermarmi
invece
a riflettere con voi
su queste cose
che di solito
uno non si chiede
c'è un esercito
e come mai c'è questo esercito
quali sforzi
appunto
magari da generazioni
hanno dovuto
essere messi in campo
perché questi eserciti
potessero affrontarsi
e per esempio
perché i cavalieri
perché nelle guerre
del medioevo
sono sempre i cavalieri
l'elemento
che conta di più
qui ci sono
delle ragioni precise
ci sono delle ragioni
tecnologiche
perché
questa è una società
naturalmente povera
con un livello
abbastanza basso
di tecnologia
un mondo contadino
anche se nelle città
ci sono mercanti
traffici
soldi
ma complessivamente
la società medievale
è una società
che produce
abbastanza poco surplus
come mai
i cavalieri
sono quelli che contano
ma perché
i fabbri medievali
nel corso dei secoli
hanno migliorato
straordinariamente
le loro tecnologie
sanno fabbricare
non soltanto
magnifiche spade
elmi
sanno fabbricare
delle cotte di maglia
la cotta di maglia
è una cosa
è un'invenzione
stupefacente
che permette
se è fatta bene
e non pesa troppo
quindi
permette
a un uomo d'armi
di combattere
restando abbastanza agile
e di essere
impenetrabile
in pratica
ai colpi di spada
ai colpi di lancia
gli deve andare
veramente male
per essere trafitto
è più facile
che lo buttino giù
da cavallo
ma insomma
fa una differenza enorme
averla o non averla
questa cotta di maglia
la cotta di maglia
è una cosa
per carità
molto pesante
30-40 chili
ma non è che
l'equipaggiamento
di un soldato di oggi
sia molto diverso
come peso
un uomo allenato
la può usare
dunque
i fabbri medievali
sanno fabbricare
queste cose
che sono ideali
specialmente
se si combatte a cavallo
e combattere a cavallo
è diventato più importante
più facile
più efficace
nel medioevo
rispetto all'epoca
degli antichi romani
perché gli antichi romani
non avevano la staffa
ora provate voi
stando a cavallo
in sella
a dare un colpo di spada
dall'alto in basso
come di solito si dava
senza avere le staffe
su cui puntellarvi
oppure a caricare
con la lancia in resta
e vedete cosa succede
nel momento in cui
se siete bravi
la lancia colpisce
l'avversario
e voi rimbalzate
lì indietro
con la staffa
invece
si può combattere a cavallo
in modo straordinariamente
più efficace
di quanto non si potesse fare
nell'antichità
tutto questo
vuol dire
che c'è una forte spinta
per privilegiare
il combattente a cavallo
chi può combattere
a cavallo
usando le staffe
usando la cotta di maglia
essendo addestrato
a usare queste cose
naturalmente
è enormemente
più efficace
che non uno
che combatte a piedi
armato al modo tradizionale
con lancia e scudo
o magari con arco e frecce
ci vogliono anche
dei cavalli
fatti apposta
per questo però
pensate un cavallo
che deve postare
un cavaliere
con l'armatura
e deve portarlo
in combattimento
a scontrarsi
fisicamente
con gli altri
cosa che ai cavalli
non piace per niente
essendo animali
molto intelligenti
i cavalli
vanno addestrati
vanno allevati apposta
ci vogliono dei cavalli
di una razza particolare
capaci di portare
questo peso
e addestrati
per fare la guerra
esattamente come
l'uomo che li cavalca
deve essere addestrato
per fare la guerra
ebbene
gli allevatori medievali
che in altri campi
non sono tanto avanti
per cui sembra
di capire
gli archeologi ci dicono
che il vestiame
in genere
è un po' più piccolo
del vestiame antico
un po' più patito
c'è meno foraggio
anche
invece i cavalli
sono formidabili
sui cavalli
c'è un grosso investimento
e i cavalieri
hanno dei cavalli
degni di loro
ma tutto questo
costa immensamente
la cotta di maglia
l'equipaggiamento
di armi
di un cavaliere
costa come
una mandria di buoi
un cavallo
da guerra
addestrato
costa
come 15
ronzini
adatti soltanto
a portare le somme
c'è la stessa differenza
che c'è tra una Ferrari
testa rossa
e la 500 usata
come prezzo
un cavaliere
armato
significa
un enorme
accumulo di ricchezza
che è stata investita
per armarlo
oltre al fatto
che lui
deve fare quello
tutta la vita
deve cominciare
già da bambino
deve essere uno
che non ha perso tempo
a zappare i campi
o a stare in bottega
naturalmente
allora
già a partire
dall'epoca di Carlo Magno
chi comanda
nella società medievale
si rende conto
che è molto meglio
avere pochi cavalieri
molto ben armati
piuttosto che non
una marmaglia
a piedi
la marmaglia a piedi
ci sarebbe
non costa molto
perché tutti i re
hanno il diritto
di convocare la gente
per fare la guerra
nel medioevo
questa è una cosa
poco nota
ma c'è
assolutamente
l'idea che le persone
devono combattere
per difendere
il loro paese
il loro popolo
la loro comunità
tutti
però
già al tempo
di Carlo Magno
ci si accorge
che far venire
tutti quanti
a piedi
anche i poveri
non serve mica molto
Carlo Magno
a un certo punto
fa una legge
dove dice
chi viene per piacere
non porti solo il bastone
almeno arco e frecce
perché quelli che vengono
con solo il bastone
non ci servono più
ma quello che conta
sono i cavalieri
e come fare
per averne un certo numero
ci vogliono 50 famiglie
contadine
che lavorano
per produrre abbastanza
sul più
da poter armare
e mantenere
un cavaliere
qual è il modo più efficace
in una società
dove circola abbastanza
poco denaro
ebbene
è di concedere terra
a delle famiglie
persone di fiducia
la terra
è la ricchezza principale
anche dei re
dei governi
allora
se io
che sono il sovrano
concedo terra
a una famiglia
di persone di fiducia
magari persone che hanno già
una certa ricchezza per conto loro
conosciute
e gli dico
in cambio di questa terra
che io vi do
in feudo
voi però
mi fornite un cavaliere
armato di tutto punto
ogni volta che devo fare la guerra
ecco
questo è il modo
più razionale
per usare
le grandi proprietà terriere
di cui un sovrano dispone
e dunque
i re del medioevo
mettono in piedi
la società feudale
quando c'erano altri rumori
a nascondere evidentemente
non c'erano neanche i microfoni
d'altra parte però
la società feudale
significa sostanzialmente questo
detto proprio molto
all'ingrosso
un meccanismo
che permette a un re
di sapere
che quando deve fare la guerra
ci sono
cinquecento
mille
mille cinquecento
cavalieri
nel suo regno
dipende da quanto è grande
questo regno
i quali sono mantenuti
stabilmente
allo scopo
di essere pronti
quando c'è da fare la guerra
su questo si reggono
le monarchie feudali
per questo gli eserciti
sono fatti essenzialmente
di cavalieri
da pochi cavalieri
le grandi battaglie
del medioevo
in cui un re
si gioca a volte
il suo regno
e la pelle
come Manfredi
quando combatte
contro Carlo D'Angio
a Benevento
o con Radino
due anni dopo
a Tagliacosto
bene queste battaglie
vengono combattute
con duemila cavalieri
per parte
perché un regno
non riesce a metterne
in campo
molti di più
talmente tanto costa
quanto alla gente a piedi
venga pure
fa comodo
le comunità contadine
mettono a disposizione
degli uomini
porteranno i carri
con il foraggio
con i rifornimenti
e poi se arrivano
con scudo e lancia
sono comodi anche loro
si mettono lì fermi
e la cavalleria
sa che c'è una zona sicura
se le cose vanno male
si può arretrare
la fanteria ti copre
hanno anche gli arcieri
qualcosa fanno
quindi vengano pure
tutti gli eserciti medievali
hanno una numerosa fanteria
in genere i cronisti
che ce li descrivono
questi eserciti
ci dicono con la massima precisione
c'erano
750 cavalieri
e moltissimi fanti
perché tanto appunto
vanno all'ingrosso
sono poi anche quelli
che vengono ammazzati
più facilmente
quando le cose vanno male
perché bene o male
i cavalieri sono a cavallo
sono armati
bene
ma è questa la situazione
a Campaldino
no
questa è solo la premessa
questo è ciò che succedeva
fino ai tempi dei bisnonni
ma Campaldino
è una battaglia
che si combatte
tra due eserciti cittadini
tra gli eserciti
di due comuni
in realtà di molti di più
perché poi ognuno
ha chiamato gli aiuti
dalle altre città guelfe
e dalle altre città
ghibelline
e allora
nei comuni
era cambiato qualcosa
perché nei comuni
rispetto a ciò
che succedeva
nel mondo
delle campagne medievali
fino a quel momento
girano molti più soldi
c'è molto più commercio
ci sono molti più traffici
c'è molta più gente
che si arricchisce
appunto
con il commercio
ancora di più
bisogna confessarlo
con l'usura
con il prestito
perché in un'economia
che cresce
succede ancora oggi
insomma
il capitale è fondamentale
e quando ce n'è poco
poter accedere al credito
è una cosa fondamentale
quindi chi ha fatto
un po' di soldi
poi in genere
li moltiplica
prestandoli
prestandoli a usura
dunque mercanti
finanzieri
gente che sta in città
gente che traffica
che fa i soldi
molta gente
molta di più
di quanto ce ne fosse
nelle campagne
tradizionali
prima che le città
ricominciassero
a svilupparsi
che l'economia
ricominciasse a crescere
più o meno
dopo l'anno 1000
cosa fanno di tutti
questi soldi
i mercanti
e gli usurai
e i finanzieri
che si sono arricchiti
se fossero imprenditori
di oggi
almeno ufficialmente
la risposta corretta
è li reinvestono
e la loro attività
cresce
un po' reinvestono
naturalmente
perché noi sappiamo
che l'economia medievale
è un'economia in crescita
secoli e secoli
di crescita sostenuta
Campaldino avviene
verso la fine
di un'epoca
in cui da secoli
l'economia cresce
e la gente lo sa
se ne accorta benissimo
c'è un ottimismo diffuso
un'intraprendenza diffusa
che sono molto caratteristiche
del mondo basso medievale
anche se noi magari
ci immaginiamo
che fossero secoli bui
invece
non è così
cosa fanno dunque
quelli che si sono arricchiti
qualcosa reinvestono
ma poi non si sa mai
la terra
è un bene che dura
l'investimento
fatto nel carico di spezzi
o di tessuti
se poi va male
se la nave affonda
se arrivano i briganti
invece la terra
una volta che l'hai comprata
dura
e del resto
la gente che conta
il re
il conte
il vescovo
i nobili
quelli
la loro ricchezza
in cosa consiste
in casse piene di denaro
no
consiste in terra
terra e contadini
che lavorano per loro
dunque anche i cittadini
che hanno fatto i soldi
cominciano a comprare la terra
e cos'altro possono comprare
che gli dia l'impressione
che sono davvero arrivati
quando è che un mercante cittadino
può dire veramente
sì adesso io non devo più
togliermi il cappello davanti
al conte Guido Guidi
per esempio
o a quegli altri nobili di campagna
che stanno nei loro castelli
comandano i contadini
compro terra innanzitutto
certo naturalmente
ma poi cos'altro posso comprare
che mi renda simile a loro
e la risposta è
cavalli
e armi
perché quello che veramente
contraddistingue il nobile
chi è il nobile?
il nobile è quello che ha dei feudi
concessi dal re
o dal conte
o dal vescovo
per potersi mantenere
come un cavaliere
i contadini
lavorano e si sporcano le mani
il cavaliere comanda
i suoi contadini
e si allena
tutto il giorno
e fa la guerra
quando il suo signore
lo chiama
noi siamo abituati a pensare
che la nobiltà
voglia dire
discendere da antenati
antichissimi
nell'epoca di cui parliamo
non era tanto così
non c'era mica nessuno
che si potesse ricordare
di grandi genealogie antiche
sì
vaghe
ricordate Dante
cacciaguida
io avevo un antenato
che è stato alle crociate
e
chi se lo ricorda
vedrà che stiamo arrivando
esattamente al punto
e che era cavaliere
tutta la fierezza di Dante
che il suo antenato
era cavaliere
e dunque
gli antenati sono una bella cosa
se ci sono
ma se non ci sono
chi ha fatto i soldi
compra i cavalli
compra le armi
comincia a imparare un po'
a usarli
soprattutto insegna i figli
perché ci vuole una generazione
o due
perché queste cose funzionino
il figlio
non va più a bottega
ma
va con i giovani eleganti
alle feste
ai tornei
magari lo invitano
storcendo un po' la bocca
però ha tanti soldi
e comunque sa andare a cavallo
sa usare le armi
sa fare il torneo
e dunque lo invitano
e a quel punto
quello è un nobile
chi era nobile
già dalla generazione precedente
lo guarda dall'alto in basso
la brava gente qualunque
lo accetta come un nobile
è più nobile di così
va in giro a cavallo
e fa i tornei
notate che noi abbiamo
processi
nell'Italia
nei comuni italiani
in cui c'è gente
che dice
io sono nobile
e dunque
ho diritto a certi privilegi
c'è un processo famoso
ad Arezzo proprio
pochi anni prima
di Campaldino
credo
in cui
i monaci
di un'abbazia
di Arezzo
rivendicano
la proprietà
di un uomo
dicendo
quello lì
è un nostro servo
è una famiglia
di nostri servi
suo nonno
era nostro servo
solo che intanto
quest'uomo
ha fatto i soldi
già il babbo
e quest'uomo
va in giro a cavallo
fa i tornei
ed è considerato
un cavaliere
e c'è un processo
in cui si chiama
la gente
per decidere
e la gente dice
ma quello lì
è un nobile
certo
l'abbiamo visto
tutti
fare il torneo
ecco
e dunque
anche gli eserciti
dei comuni
per mettere in campo
della cavalleria
si devono basare
innanzitutto
sul fatto che
loro hanno
tanti cittadini
che hanno i cavalli
hanno le armi
se li sono comprati
non hanno dovuto
aspettare
che ci fosse
un sovrano
che gli dava
un feudo
si sono fatti da sé
e sono diventati
però a tutti gli effetti
cavalieri
e quando c'è da fare
la guerra
tutto sommato
a guardarli
tutti schierati
con le loro cotte di maglia
i loro insegni
i loro scudi
con lo stemma
non è che li distingui
dai cavalieri
messi in campo
dal re di Francia
o dal re normanno
dell'Italia meridionale
che sono
uno potrebbe dire
veri, nobili
no, è la stessa cosa
in fondo
sono tutti cavalieri
all'estero
ci guardano un po'
dall'alto in basso
va detto
perché ci sono testimonianze
per esempio tedesche
che dicono
sì, gli italiani
lì appena uno
un artigiano
uno che si è sporcato
le mani tutta la vita
ha i soldi
subito diventa cavaliere
e il sottinteso
è che l'Italia
è un paese un po' strano
è anche
un po' spreggevole
tutto sommato
pensano
nell'ambiente
della corte imperiale
ecco
però questo è quello
che succede
e siccome di gente
che ha fatto i soldi
ce n'è tanta
accade quest'altra cosa
miracolosa
che come vi dicevo
l'imperatore
quando deve venire
in Italia
con un grande esercito
e costringe
tutti i principi
e i vescovi tedeschi
a mettergli a disposizione
le loro clientele
di vassalli
armati
alla fine conta
e se ha
1500 cavalieri
va bene
perché come vi ripeto
una società rurale
fa un'enorme fatica
a mantenere
dei cavalieri
con quel che costano
1500 cavalieri
sono un esercito
ma Firenze
da sola
se ne vuole mettere
in campo
5 o 600
non ci mette niente
e 4 o 5
buone città
alleate
mettono in campo
facilmente
un esercito
più grande
di quello
dell'imperatore
proprio perché
i loro cavalieri
sono
come dire
rispecchiano
la ricchezza
che circola
in città
e poi però
c'è ancora
un altro fatto
che dopo tutto
sì abbiamo detto
il mercante
che si è arricchito
può decidere
di investire
i suoi soldi
nella scalata
alla nobiltà
e quindi
far sposare il figlio
magari alla figlia
di un cavaliere
e comprargli
i cavalli
le armi
mantenerlo
a fare i tornei
ma non è poi detto
che sia obbligato
naturalmente
c'è anche
tanta gente
che ha fatto i soldi
e che magari
non c'è ancora arrivata
a decidere
di fare questa cosa
a un certo momento
i governi comunali
si rendono conto
di questo fatto
che in città
diciamo va bene
ci sono quelle
5-600 persone
che si sa
che gli piace
farsi chiamare
i cavalieri
e quindi
hanno
i cavalli
e le armi
e loro
quando si è da fare la guerra
su loro si può contare
ma ci stanno
anche tanti bottegai
che si sa
che i soldi
li avrebbero
e però
non l'hanno ancora fatto
questo passo
di trasformarsi
in cavalieri
ma fare la guerra
è una cosa importante
fare una guerra
è una cosa decisiva
ottimizzare le risorse
per la guerra
è uno scopo
di tutti i governi
anche dei governi
delle città italiane
del medioevo
e allora
in un certo momento
nessuno potrebbe dire
chi ha cominciato
ma al tempo
di Campaldino
succede già
dappertutto
in tutte le città
è passato
questo principio
c'è poco da fare
chi ha abbastanza soldi
e si potrebbe permettere
un cavallo
da guerra
lo deve avere
e lo deve mettere
a disposizione
del comune
e quando il comune
fa la guerra
deve venire
questo cavallo
con un cavaliere sopra
se ci va sopra
il padrone
benissimo
vuole trovarsi
un mercenario
che però
sappia farlo
il mestiere
va bene lo stesso
la cosa più difficile
sono i cavalli
i cavalli sono la cosa
più cara in assoluto
e muoiono
insomma
non ce n'è mai abbastanza
e allora
poi in tutti i comuni italiani
passa il principio
che chi ha
un livello di reddito
sufficiente
deve tenere
un cavallo da guerra
per il comune
e voi capite
le implicazioni
le implicazioni sono
sballorditive
per la mentalità
di allora
il comune
ha il diritto
di chiedere alla gente
quanto guadagna
il governo
vuole sapere
quanto guadagnano
gli imprenditori
e vuole poter dire
tu sei abbastanza ricco
ti mettiamo
nella lista
di quelli
che devono avere
il cavallo
vedete anche voi
quante cose
possono venire fuori
da questa intuizione
che un qualche assessore
ha avuto
a un certo punto
non c'erano gli assessori
in realtà
ma insomma
un governo comunale
ha avuto
e che in tutte le città
si è poi diffuso
ed ecco che quindi
gli eserciti
che si affrontano
a Campaldino
sono composti
innanzitutto
da cavalieri
ma
se noi andiamo a vedere
chi sono questi cavalieri
molti
sono quelli
che in città
sono abituati
ormai a chiamarsi
nobili
perché è già
il nonno
il bisnonno
quello che ha fatto
i soldi
col traffico
con l'usura
e ormai
i nipoti
tutti li conoscono
come cavalieri
ci sono quelli
che non sono proprio
di quell'ambiente
ma vorrebbero
esserlo
Dante
è di nuovo
un perfetto esempio
Dante
è uno di famiglia
relativamente modesta
però insomma
i mezzi per armarsi
li ha
e in famiglia
c'è questa tradizione
che un antenato
è stato alle crociate
e quindi anche noi
anche se non siamo
purtroppo i cavalcanti
o i brunelleschi
o i donati
siamo molto al di sotto
come livello
però anche noi
a Lighieri
in guerra
ci andiamo
col cavallo
e l'armatura
e poi ci sono tutti quelli
che magari non ci andrebbero
ma che il governo
li costringe a andarci
li costringe a tenere i cavalli
e a quel punto
ci vanno loro
o trovano un sostituto
e questa è la cavalleria
delle città italiane
come vedete
questo è il punto
a cui volevo arrivare
il modo in cui
si è messo in campo
questo esercito
è totalmente diverso
dal modo in cui
lo metteva in campo
l'imperatore
o un qualunque re europeo
che si basava
sulle concessioni
di feudi
e sull'esistenza quindi
di una nobiltà
ereditaria
di cavalieri
che avevano questi feudi
e di padre in figlio
è tutto diverso
ma il risultato
poi è lo stesso
un esercito di cavalieri
perché quello offre
la tecnologia
che loro hanno a disposizione
in quel momento
quello è il modo più efficiente
per fare la guerra
e la gente a piedi
tutti questi famosi
fanti con i loro pavesi
che da lontano
al vescovo di Arezzo
che era mio
che sembravano
le mura di una città
quelli chi sono?
e quelli sono tutti
gli altri cittadini
perché comunque
c'è il principio
che se tu fai parte
di una comunità
sei tenuto
a combattere
quando c'è la guerra
questo vale per tutti
se sei un contadino
suddito di un signore
che dal castello comanda
però il signore
ha il diritto
di dirti
guarda che devo fare
la guerra
quindi mandatemi
degli uomini
dei cavalli
dei mezzi
dei carri
è un dovere
tanto più
per i cittadini
di un libero comune
i quali vivono
in un sistema
relativamente democratico
fine 200
è forse il momento
in cui tocca il massimo
l'allargamento
diciamo fra virgolette
democratico
dei comuni italiani
per cui chiunque
abiti in città
sia padrone
di una casa
e di una bottega
di un'attività
comunque
e quindi paghi le tasse
ebbene
ha diritto
ha diritto di voto
o può essere sorteggiato
per certi uffici
del comune
e così via
per il medioevo
è una realtà
decisamente larga
ebbene
cosa fa
quando c'è la guerra
il venditore di formaggio
il bottegaio all'angolo
il ciabattino
anche lui deve andare
e improvvisa
no che non può improvvisare
anche lì
nelle città medievali
chiunque fosse un cittadino
a pieno titolo
quindi diciamo
un piccolissimo imprenditore
perlomeno
padrone di casa
con una famiglia
qualche domestico
un apprendista
una bottega
dei soldi
ebbene aveva anche le armi in casa
tutti avevano le armi in casa
normalmente
lo scudo
la lancia
magari un elmetto
se te lo sei potuto comprare
oppure se ti piace
la balestra
perché per chi vuole divertirsi
c'è la balestra
costa di più
però
tutti se la possono permettere
e la balestra
è un'arma da lancio
naturalmente bisogna imparare a usarla
e
saperla usare
è una cosa che viene incoraggiata
si fanno
le gare
ci sono le associazioni
per l'uso della balestra
in modo che
quando c'è da fare la guerra
un certo numero di cittadini
chiudono la bottega
prendono la balestra
e vanno
in guerra
con l'esercito del comune
e gli altri
vanno appunto
con la lancia
la picca
in spalla
e lo scudo
di legno
appeso dietro
e basta
come armamento
molto probabilmente
e non vanno certo individualmente
perché questa è una società collettivista
è una società
dove un uomo
fa sempre parte
di organizzazioni
gruppi
società
associazioni
e così via
se tu vai in guerra
è perché
nel tuo quartiere
tutte le domeniche
ci si addestra
tutti insieme
tutti i vicini
a usare
la picca
e lo scudo
si fa un minimo di addestramento
e quando si va in guerra
si va tutti insieme
tutti quelli
dell'associazione di quartiere
oppure tutti quelli
dell'associazione dei ciabattini
e tutte queste associazioni
naturalmente
sono benedette
hanno un rapporto
con la parrocchia
il parroco
li benedice
prima di andare
e hanno le loro insegne
le loro insegne
che possono ricordare
sia l'insegna cittadina
a Firenze sarà il giglio
sia la croce
visto che siamo pur sempre
i guelfi
e cioè il partito
di santa chiesa
o magari anche
le insegne
dell'associazione
del quartiere
del santo del quartiere
cioè fare la guerra
vuol dire
continuare a fare
ciò che si faceva prima
il cittadino
fra i suoi obblighi
a
fare il suo mestiere
tenere bottega aperta
far parte di una confraternita
far parte di una parrocchia
fa delle lemosine
fa parte di altri tipi
di associazioni
di associazioni di mestiere
fa politica
attraverso queste associazioni
e fa la guerra
tramite le compagnie
organizzate per questo
dunque questi sono eserciti
essenzialmente
di popolo
se vogliamo chiamarli così
e l'intera comunità
di un comune
cittadino
che mette in gioco
la sua pelle
per fare la guerra
quando ce n'è bisogno
noi potremmo pensare
che di conseguenza
la facessero di rado
invece la facevano
abbastanza spesso
è evidente
che a fare la guerra
c'era anche da guadagnare
specialmente
i più grossi
avevano da guadagnare
quelli che rischiavano
di meno la pelle
i cavalieri
loro avevano da guadagnare parecchio
il bottino
quando le cose andavano bene
lo facevano loro
la guerra all'epoca
si faceva
non necessariamente
andando a cercare la battaglia
battaglia
quando proprio le cose
erano inevitabili
ma altrimenti
la guerra si faceva
entrando nel paese del nemico
e portando via tutto
portando via il bestiame
devastando naturalmente
tagliando le vigne
tagliando gli olivi
ma poi portando via
tutto quello che si trovava
costringendo i contadini
a tirar fuori i soldi
nascosti sotto la mattonella
si tornava a casa
arricchiti
se c'era un combattimento
e andava bene
i cavalieri
di solito fra loro
non si ammazzavano
per un ottimo motivo
che era onorevole
e ufficialmente previsto
dalle regole della cavalleria
che chi era stato sconfitto
e catturato
pagasse un riscatto
e si negoziava
questo riscatto
il prigioniero
scriveva a casa
la moglie
raccoglieva i soldi
prendeva il prestito
dal banchiere
mandava i soldi
e chi aveva catturato
un prigioniero
si arricchiva
oltre a tenersi
le sue armi
il suo cavallo
e così via
dunque la guerra
poteva essere un grosso affare
specialmente
per i cavalieri
la pelle
lo abbiamo detto
non la rischiavano
poi troppo
per quanto
poteva succedere
a Campaldino succede
lo vedremo
rischiavano il cavallo
perché i cavalli
sono vulnerabili
i cavalli
sono fragili
in battaglia
nello scontro
prima di ammazzare
il cavaliere
in armatura
ce ne vuole
ma il cavallo
per storpiarlo
rovinarlo
non ci vuole niente
lo sapevano bene
e siccome i cavalieri
erano come avete capito
il certo dirigente
del comune
i più ricchi
della città
quelli che avevano più mezzi
e che quindi
badavano anche
a far passare le leggi
che facevano comodo a loro
in tutti i comuni
c'erano precise leggi
che dicevano
se un cavaliere
perde un cavallo
combattendo
o comunque
durante una campagna militare
una spedizione
al servizio della città
ha diritto
al risarcimento
lui dichiara
il valore
della cavalcatura
che ha perso
e viene pagato
in contanti
quindi tranquilli
da quel punto di vista lì
si può andare in guerra
effettivamente
è un grandioso affare
anche
ma è anche
un regolamento di conti
quando si arriva
alla battaglia
e perché davvero
non se ne può più
davvero
si è arrivati al punto
in cui
diciamo come nei film western
qui non c'è più spazio
per tutti e due
uno dei due
deve cedere
e questo è quello
che succede a Campaldino
a un certo punto
Campaldino
è l'ultimo tentativo
degli aretini
e dei ghibellini toscani
in genere
di contestare
il predominio
dei fiorentini
e del partito guelfo
in Toscana
è un tentativo
perdente
fin dall'inizio
lo si capisce
infatti i cronisti
dell'epoca
ci fanno leggere
fra le righe
il fatto che gli aretini
erano molto in dubbio
e che i fiorentini
invece erano molto convinti
di andare a fare
questa guerra
però
però non si sa mai
in una battaglia
di cavalieri
che vede
non grandi eserciti
avete visto
poche centinaia
di uomini
per parte
beh chi sa
può succedere di tutto
i fiorentini
avevano tanta cavalleria
ma erano appunto
in gran parte
mercanti
che avevano fatto
i soldi da poco
gli aretini
avevano più nobili
di antica data
più gente
che pensava
di essere specialmente
capace di fare la guerra
perché già i bisnonni
la facevano
gli aretini
si fidano
sul fatto
di essere più bravi
di essere più coraggiosi
e che anche se sono molti meno
potrebbero anche farcela
e in ogni caso
non hanno scelta
perché se accettano
il diktat di Firenze
perdono la loro autonomia politica
e dunque
escono da Arezzo
avanzano nel Casentino
vanno a schierarsi
anche loro
nella piana di Poppi
e quel giorno
l'11 giugno
del 1289
a un certo punto
questi due eserciti
si trovano di fronte
e i comandanti
almeno questo è quello
che ci raccontano
dopo i cronisti
hanno tutto il tempo
di passare a cavallo
davanti alle schiere
sono piccole queste schiere
1500 cavalieri
d'accordo
sono tanti
ma mettili su alcune file
è un fronte
di poche centinaia di metri
le battaglie medievali
sono piccolissime
rispetto a quelle
dell'epoca moderna
e contemporanea
e prima che il nemico
che ha avvistato
in lontananza
sia abbastanza vicino
da essere pericoloso
c'è tutto il tempo
di guardarlo
di ragionare
di organizzarsi
di aver paura
di cercare di superarla
Dante per esempio
avrebbe raccontato
in una lettera
che è andata perduta
ma che fu vista
dal suo biografo
Leonardo Bruni
nel Rinascimento
Dante avrebbe raccontato
che all'inizio
di quella battaglia
di paura ne aveva avuta
perché gli aretini
venivano avanti
erano dei bei cavalieri
erano di meno
ma erano belli
e facevano paura
e dunque la battaglia
è una battaglia
che a questo punto
si risolve
con i mezzi tecnologici
a disposizione
chi le risolverà?
i cavalieri
i fanti cosa possono fare?
star fermi
e tener duro
stanno tutti schierati
dietro i loro scudi
hanno delle lunghe picche
è difficile
che la cavalleria
gli venga dentro
proprio in pieno
certo però
nel disordine
di una battaglia
può succedere di tutto
e se il fronte
dei fanti schierati
con i loro scudi
e le loro picche
si rompe
se i cavalieri nemici
ci entrano in mezzo
allora cosa succede?
succede che scappano
tutti a gambe elevate
naturalmente
vengono massacrati
quindi i fanti
sono stati addestrati
a una cosa sola
stare fermi lì
la prima fila
magari in ginocchio
le picche ben piantate
nel terreno
e sperare che il nemico
non gli venga addosso
ci verranno semmai
i nostri
a ritirarsi dietro
a rifugiarsi
a riposarsi un po'
un gruppo per volta
perché i cavalieri
sono divisi in gruppi
non è che le battaglie medievali
siano fatte
da barbari
che si buttano
gli uni contro gli altri
urlando
e tutto finisce lì
sono battaglie
anzi che hanno
una loro regia
i cavalieri
sono divisi in gruppi
anche loro
in base alla città
di provenienza
ogni famiglia
con i suoi cavalieri
con i suoi vicini
con i suoi amici
con bandiere comuni
le bandiere
sono importantissime
perché nel caos
nel disordine
nella polvere
tutto quello
che uno può capire
nella battaglia
è
devo star vicino
alla mia bandiera
lì ci sono gli altri
lì c'è il mio comandante
quindi le bandiere
hanno un'importanza fondamentale
è pieno di bandiere
ogni 10
20 cavalieri
sono un'unità
con una loro insegna
riconoscibile
e i comandanti
decidono
si va dentro
con un primo gruppo
gli altri di riserva
e poi si vede
vediamo un po'
come va la prima mischia
se i nostri arretrano
se ne mandano
dentro degli altri
anche il nemico
le manderà dentro
degli altri
pian piano
un gruppo
può provare
a fare il giro
se riuscissero
a prenderli di fianco
allora
è la volta
che li freghiamo
però bisogna avere occhio
calcolare bene
perché se si fa il giro
troppo largo
rischia di finire tutto
prima che siano arrivati
e il momento
di lanciarsi dentro
va calcolato
di nuovo
con occhio
perché se si parte
da troppo lontano
i cavalli arrivano
spompati
non va bene
dunque sono battaglie
calcolate
ripeto
con una loro
regia
gli arretini
attaccano
perché stanno
giocandosi
il tutto per tutto
mandano dentro
la maggioranza
dei loro cavalieri
dall'una parte
e dall'altra
si sono messi
in prima fila
soprattutto i giovani
quelli che hanno più voglia
di far vedere
chi sono
quelli che ancora
non hanno dimostrato
agli occhi di tutti
che sono
per usare
un'espressione
di un altro cronista
italiano
del 300
che non parla di questo
parla di un altro scontro
ma vale da pena
lo stesso
di usare questa espressione
questo cronista
che è l'anonimo romano
quando parla
di un guerriero
che vuol far vedere
insomma
quello che vale
dice
ora si vedrà
chi è figlio
di buona mamma
questo è quello
che pensano tutti
i giovani
per esortarli
ancora di più
a far vedere
il loro coraggio
qualcuno è stato
armato cavaliere
con la cerimonia solenne
che fa di lui
un privilegiato
con dei diritti speciali
non soltanto uno
che ha le armi
e i cavalli
ma un vero nobile
ecco
si è fatta questa cerimonia
sul campo di battaglia
quel mattino stesso
è chiaro che
chi è stato armato
cavaliere quel mattino
davanti a tutti
farà vedere chi è
e dunque
gli aretini
vengono dentro
con la maggioranza
dei loro cavalieri
e invece i fiorentini
hanno mandato avanti
una forza più ristretta
150 cavalieri
Dante
sempre secondo
quella famosa lettera
che è perduta
ma sembra proprio
che ci fosse
era fra quei
il primo gruppo
che si è preso la botta
dell'attacco degli aretini
che erano di più
e che si stavano giocando
il tutto per tutto
risultato
i fiorentini
arretrano
è lì che Dante dice
per un momento
ho pensato che andasse a finire
molto male
e ho avuto paura
naturalmente i comandanti
ci sono per un motivo
sono lì
per gestire la situazione
mandar dentro
rinforzi
mandano dentro
un po' per volta
e un po' per volta
lo slancio degli aretini
si spegne
i cavalieri
non caricano tutti
su un'unica linea
naturalmente
caricano in massa
molte file
i più coraggiosi
davanti
perché all'inizio
sono gli unici
che rischiano davvero qualcosa
quelli della prima fila
gli altri dietro
devono solo spingere
se va tutto bene
non rischiano niente
sono poi quelli
che perdono
quando scappano
che rischiano di essere
raggiunti e ammazzati
ma finché c'è la mischia
sono solo quelli in prima fila
che rischiano davvero
che prendono le botte
e gli aretini
hanno attaccato
con tanto impeto
dicono i cronisti
che i primi della fila
sono finiti in mezzo
alla schiera
dei fiorentini
cosa che di solito
non succedeva
per cui anche dei fiorentini
che stavano in quarta fila
di colpo
si sono trovati
il nemico davanti
e qualcuno è stato ammazzato
in un posto
dove sembrava
che non si dovesse rischiare
assolutamente niente
di solito
questo per dire
quanto era stata
forte e impetuosa
questa carica
dei ghibellini
degli aretini
poi però lentamente
i numeri contano
i fiorentini
sono di più
da tutte e due le parti
la fanteria
è ferma
dietro i suoi scudi
e i balestrieri
sono lì che lanciano
cercando di colpire
di più il nemico
ovviamente
quando c'è la mischia
sarà difficile
ma finché si stavano
ancora avvicinando
tirano
ci dicono che tirano anche dopo
finché ci sono frecce
quelli con le balestre
tirano
grosso modo
in direzione del nemico
l'aria è piena
di queste quadrelle
come si chiamano
che possono fare un po' male
quelle a un cavaliere
quando lo prendono
quelle sì
se lo prendono
con l'angolatura giusta
possono perforare
anche la cotta di maglia
e poi la battaglia
va avanti
e pian piano
gli aretini
vengono respinti indietro
tanto che si finisce
in mezzo ai loro fanti
e i loro fanti
rischiano di essere travolti
da questa massa di cavalieri
che combattendo ormai
con le spade
perché le lance sono rotte
da un bel pezzo
e quindi ormai si combatte
con le spade
si spingono in mezzo ai fanti
certi fanti
coraggiosi evidentemente
si buttano per terra
e da sotto
con i coltelli
squarciano la pancia
i cavalli
dei cavalieri fiorentini
polvere
che non ci si vede niente
urla
frastuola
non si capisce niente
se non stiamo vicini
alla bandiera
a un certo momento
i fiorentini
hanno una riserva in più
hanno i cavalieri pistoiesi
Pistoia in quel momento
aveva un po' d'està
fiorentino
Corso Donati
che comanda quindi
questo gruppo di
forse 300 cavalieri pistoiesi
loro sono rimasti di riserva
loro
quando ormai
gli aretini hanno impegnato
tutte le loro forze
fanno il giro sul fianco
li investono sul fianco
e a quel punto
gli aretini
vanno in rotta
ho detto prima
ho insistito forse
un po' troppo
su questo fatto
che
nelle battaglie medievali
non si moriva facilmente
in realtà
quando una battaglia
si trasforma
in una rotta
e uno dei due eserciti
è veramente sbaragliato
è messo in fuga
allora lì
si rischia
che qualcuno muoia
e anche tanti
i cronisti ci dicono
una cosa particolare
ci sono stati tanti morti
perché i fiorentini
avevano anche dei mercenari
e già
questa è una novità
che non vi ho detto
perché vi ho parlato
di questi eserciti
di popolo
che rispecchiano
la comunità cittadina
però non vi ho detto
che in questi anni
siamo un po'
verso la fine
di quest'epoca
delle città
che mettono in campo
eserciti formati
dai loro cittadini
siamo un po'
verso la fine
perché appunto
quelli che si divertono
a farla
la guerra
tutto sommato
non sono più così tanti
e c'è tanta gente
che ormai
è agiata
a dei traffici importanti
e preferirebbe stare a casa
e continuare a lavorare
c'è un po'
questa mentalità
che sta cominciando
a venire fuori
e allora
di tutti quei soldi
che sono disponibili
in città
i governi
stanno cominciando
a pensare
se non si possono fare
anche degli altri usi
oltre a costringere
i cittadini stessi
ad armarsi
forse
con i soldi
delle tasse
si potrebbero
pagare
dei mercenari
e i mercenari
si trovano
il mondo è pieno
di nobili impoveriti
che una cosa
sanno fare
la guerra
e quindi
sono disposti
a prestare servizio
per chi li paga
la grande epoca
dei mercenari
sarà poi
il 300
il 400
ma già
in quest'epoca
qui
si comincia
a sentirne parlare
Firenze
ha investito
dei soldi
anche
per prendere
dei mercenari
e i mercenari
non sono
dilettanti
prestati
dalla vita civile
e non sono
come dire
cavalieri
che vogliono
farsi vedere
in tutto il loro splendore
e la loro bellezza
per essere omaggiati
e riveriti
dai concittadini
sono gente dura
che fa la guerra
esclusivamente
per guadagnare
per vincere
e ci dicono
sempre i cronisti
dell'epoca
sono loro
che ci raccontano
queste cose
altrimenti
non le sapremmo
ecco
i mercenari
loro sapevano
che quando
il nemico
scappa
non è il momento
di dire
abbiamo vinto
e andare
a festeggiare
ma è il momento
di inseguire
massacrare
far bottino
e dunque
gli aretini
vengono inseguiti
per tutto il pomeriggio
la sera
la notte
moltissimi morti
moltissimi prigionieri
anche
muore fra gli altri
il vescovo
Guglielmino
degli ubertini
quello che aveva cercato
fino all'ultimo
di evitare la cosa
accordandosi con i fiorentini
e poi però aveva visto
che non ce la poteva fare
e dunque era sceso in guerra
anche lui
con i suoi cavalieri
con i suoi vassalli
e c'è rimasto anche lui
muore Bonconte da Montefeltro
uno
dei comandanti
aretini
perché vi cito
Bonconte da Montefeltro
perché
vedo fra l'altro
che il mio tempo
sta finendo
e mi avvio a chiudere
anche perché
vorremmo lasciare
qualche minuto
per delle domande
eventualmente
Bonconte da Montefeltro
è importante
forse per un unico motivo
che Dante
sapeva bene
chi era
lo conosceva bene
è rimasto colpito
dalla sua morte
Dante ha combattuto
dalla parte dei vincitori
in quella battaglia
e Bonconte da Montefeltro
uno
dei comandanti
dell'esercito ghibellino
è scomparso
nella battaglia di Campaldino
durante l'inseguimento
e non è mai più
stato ritrovato
e Dante
a un certo punto
nella commedia
decide
di provare
a immaginarsi
cosa gli è successo
anche questa
se volete
è creatività
che nasce
dalla guerra
anche se è un po' diversa
da quella
che è di solito
così
ci immaginiamo
siamo nel purgatorio
canto quinto
purgatorio
Bonconte
è un nemico
è un ghibellino
nemico della santa chiesa
però
però era un nobile cavaliere
era un grande soldato
un uomo ben conosciuto
è morto
in una disfatta
scomparso per sempre
Dante
non dico che si sarà chiesto
magari l'ho ammazzato io
non vorrei romanticheggiare troppo
c'è questo rischio
però certamente
è rimasto colpito
dal suo destino
e ha voluto
riscattarlo
da questo destino
e lo incontra
dunque Dante
nel purgatorio
incontra Bonconte
io fui di Montefeltro
io sono Bonconte
altri versi
che non citiamo
e poi Dante
gli parla
e io a lui
qual forza
o qual ventura
ti traviosi
fuor di Campaldino
che non si seppe mai
tua sepultura
cioè cosa ti è successo
che sei andato a finire
così lontano
e il tuo corpo
non è mai più stato ritrovato
oh
risposelli
a piede il casentino
traversa un'acqua
un fiume
che a nome l'archiano
che sovra l'ermo
nasce in appennino
laove il vocabol suo
diventa vano
arrivai io
forato nella gola
fuggendo a piede
e sanguinando il piano
cioè insanguinando
la pianura
dove lui si muoveva
a piedi
ferito alla gola
moribondo
Dante
se lo sta immaginando
nessuno sa
cosa è successo
a Bonconte
ma Dante
sa cosa poteva succedere
a un cavaliere
che veniva ferito
inseguito dai nemici
aveva perso il cavallo
e che poi se ne andava a morire
chissà dove
qui vi perdei
la vista
e la parola
nel nome di Maria
finii
e qui vi
caddi
e rimase
la mia carne sola
e cioè
è cieco
non può più parlare
ma può ancora
rivolgersi a Maria
e
alzare un'ultima invocazione
alla Vergine
e questo è quello
che lo salva evidentemente
quest'unico istante
teologicamente
non fa una grinza
è sufficiente
per salvarlo
rimane la mia carne sola
cioè
il cadavere
il corpo
perché l'anima
parte
e il diavolo
vorrebbe acchiapparla
quanti quadri abbiamo visto
in cui c'è il diavolo
e l'angelo
che si disputano
l'anima che sale
il diavolo vorrebbe acchiapparla
ma l'angelo arriva
e lo prende
e lo porta in paradiso
e rimane
il corpo
rimane il corpo
sale la nebbia
viene il temporale
la pioggia cadde
e
il suo corpo
portato
dal
disgregarsi del terreno
sotto il diluvio
finisce
nell'archiano
e poi
l'archiano
lo porta
fin nell'arno
e nell'arno
sparisce
ecco
anche questo
dicevo creatività
forse un po' barato
parlando di
Lepanto
e parlando di
Waterloo
non potrò chiudere
con Dante
e di conseguenza
la chiusa sarà inevitabilmente
credo
meno efficace
però per Campaldino
ho scelto di chiudere così
grazie
grazie a tutti